c'est une pièce mythique un vêtement
intergénérationnel qui s'expose à la
cité des sciences à paris
le jean troué détachées déchiré délavé
ils se portent n'importe où n'importe
quand et ça depuis des décennies à
l'origine j'aime bien comme ça ça des
vagues un peu attendre un peu les plus
mignons le jeans à l'origine c'est un
vêtement de travail
inventé par un industriel américain levi
strauss car la moitié du 19e siècle
cet abri camp de jean le raconter en
1970 c'est en 1850 comme celle existant
ce qui était lui-même chercheurs d'or a
éludé de fabriquer ses bougies n'en
parle trouver lui-même de l'or aux états
unis il devient le vêtement fétiche des
cow boys du des acteurs comme marlon
brando et james dean en france les gi's
l'un porte pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale mais dans la capitale de la
mode
le vêtement est mal vu c'est un symbole
de la jeunesse contestataire
il est parfois banni des cours de récré
le bout jean parce que le budget ne tout
tous les films nouvelle vague avait
avait des acteurs avec des blue-jeans
alors les proviseurs et les directeurs
de lycées ont eu peur que la nouvelle
vague s'installant les études les est
une nouvelle vague c'était pas très
agréable pour eux parce qu'il fallait
tout changer
à partir des années 60 le jean devient
symbole du mouvement hippie c'est un
pantalon cool on lebron dont le décor il
s'élargit en pattes d'éléphant bref elle
se démocratise
même les créateurs s'y intéresse à
l'image du styliste françois girbaud qui
martyrise un jean en 1975 le denim
c'était quand même assez fantastique le
fait que ce matin à l'indigo qu'ensuite
ils décolore ça c'est une chose est par
ailleurs bon c'est ça une solide et
fantastique prend une cigarette une
fille grèce comme ces chômage 1
on hamm est sûre le slam est sur mon
pantalon je laisse mon lait on laisse
encore se frottent ya rien monde c'est
vachement cesser de traiter vraiment
costaud dans les années 80 le jean reste
un vêtement incontournable même si les
jeux ne délaisse parfois au profit
d'autres vêtements plus confortables
maintenant il ya beaucoup de choses qui
ne sont pas causés ou on peut être
bien bien au large puis en plus de
couleurs c'est monotone dans le jean un
lac du bleu marine ou alors il ya vu
jean délavé mais c'est quand même pas
l'idée est pourtant le jeans fait
toujours partie des basiques de notre
armoire taille haute
jean slim et skinny ou encore le regular
il y en a pour tous les goûts
et certains sont même prêts à y mettre
le prix 650 euros
je préfère manger des patates
[Musique]